[Applause]
buttons
english invention you made up english
you're guessing
i know for a fact sugar indian invention
the bond movie with the character odd
job
in it that has the topic everybody
watching this dumb ass movie
well i wanted to throw this hat at you
so hard when you just said that indian
indians invented sugar they did they did
not invent sugar
how do you think we got them sloppy ass
midriffs say again how do you think we
have them sloppy ass music yeah
no [ __ ] hair on it you did not invent
sugar the first
chemically refined sugar appeared on the
scene in india and about
2500 years ago that's what i said trust
the black guy
no no no no yeah there we go there we go
first
sugar some brown and black your neck
maybe how many years ago did you say
hurting your feelings how many years ago
2 500.
you ain't
[Applause]
which one is god give us a fact
jesus brown say what how do you think
they get brown
i miss them
yo that is some white [ __ ] to do like
yeah white people took sugar that is
brown and they were like
eat that's a little
dangerous why is that sugar so loud
turn down the music of that bad inside
of me son we literally did that to
chocolate and sugar
yeah we made white chocolate we made
white chocolate for no [ __ ] reasons
and we made white sugar for no [ __ ]
reason but
real keep it 100 same with bread too we
made white bread
and what color is weeds and all of our
words
once you make it white it takes all the
nutrients out it's all the flavor
just like white people takes all the
salt out of it amber
[ __ ] making sense that [ __ ] is amber
this [ __ ] is and we made it white for no
reason
y'all are racist this [ __ ] is making
this
really racist nick cannon was on to
something
none of you guys
wait a minute why did we turn everything
white mark
i think aesthetics i think we wanted it
all to match aesthetics i knew that she
was aesthetics
yeah oh my god bro yeah we did it to
sugar
we did it to brent we did it too what
was the other day and they're funny that
aesthetics for y'all
involves taking away all ass in that
true
what else did we do it to what else did
we do it to guys what else would we turn
white marble
white rice
rice we turned [ __ ] rice white
did we yeah rice is brown mark facts
do not care about your feelings right
now dude we're going off of feelings
okay okay feelings don't care about your
facts that's what i mean neither of them
yeah we have rice that got turned white
what else got turned white
huh huh
we turn them white yeah geishas geishas
right maybe right about that yo yeah i
used to get as white as possible with
makeup you would [ __ ]
white it up put the little high pink
blush on white hair
white hair white wigs turn hair white
bruh that's how much we love white [ __ ]
we got fake hair and chose for it to be
white
that's crazy usually people would choose
like a luscious brown or blonde if you
will
or indian most of the time most of the
time indian brown hair
probably straight off of a girl's nipple
do you think that's what they make wigs
out of
you think they just shaved out girls
titties
they make a nice
i ain't seen a single bald indian [ __ ]
in india but apparently all that hair is
coming from india
i think it's coming from titty hair you
know how soul food is the worst parts of
the animal and then you make
oh god city hair makes weaves
worst part of the titty now we turn it
into a business
and that's why black women were like
don't touch my hair because that's
sexual assault
i think we're on to something real talk
that's why you got to start with
something crazy kamala being a
hypothetical foe
is going to get us to black girls weaves
are made by indian city hair
hey man i can't deny the facts you can't
deny it
they don't care about my feelings done
mark is there anything that you're
looking up right now
no i'm trying to figure out where sugar
comes from
tobago he's dropping the balls trinidad
comes from what
sugar comes from trinidad and tobago's
and also the other caribbean islands
yes that is a fact maybe now it does
we got our own ship no you didn't you've
never had sugar
they had sugar before never had sugar
they never had
sugar before you had jesus y'all slow yo
that
man's slow that's another thing we turn
white
we miss that one we need to turn this
[ __ ]
white bro bro oh if you want to grow up
in the suburbs oh
[ __ ] what color are the picket fences
why picket fences
in your ideal white world oh
my goodness christ this is
unbelievable white people have turned
everything white to normalize
whiteness to make that the status quo
what did she why didn't any of y'all
think of that what color are these
floors
white yeah
why are none of y'all thinking that
that's a good point you guys always talk
about colonization
we all talk about colonization but why
the [ __ ] did y'all come up with these
ideas why are you guys colonizing to
slave a whole race why didn't you do
that
wait what mark what you didn't have to
go that deep with it
yeah why didn't you i really i mean man
indians tried we just didn't get the
boat yeah i mean i said we [ __ ] up we
didn't take it international
we did that [ __ ] to our own you did it
to your own yeah man because you had
enough people
you think that's what it was you already
had enough
right right or no is it am i wrong
which one is it
i thought she was reacting away i was
like oh
this is a funny rationale no but yo
white people we always knock for
traveling al
i think that's what they're doing
they're scouting son oh my goodness
you know why people i just love to
travel you scouting ass [ __ ]
scouting ass barefoot ass [ __ ] you
scouting ass barefoot ass [ __ ] whenever
you're going like a mission trip to
africa
yeah i know the mission oh oh my god
dude so are you saying that mormons
are not actually these kind of like
devout christians
they are the first line for the new
colonization what color are their shirts
oh my goodness oh my goodness i'm about
to blow your mind
the natural color of cotton
ranges from tan to green to brown what
the [ __ ] is going on dude son what
come on son come on
the natural color of cotton what website
did you get that from thanks for taking
us to america.org
no dude that's crazy white people just
make anything white that they do
so what color are churches jesus white
we'll call our churches are they white
usually white sometimes yeah yeah
sometimes they're wood this guy gets in
the studio
paints this whole [ __ ] yeah the floors
white yeah
but i wasn't the one who decided that
a white man did a half white man a half
asian man
both white that's an interesting thing
yeah how do you think
how do you think he got half white and
half asian tell me probably his dad was
like yo let's make some [ __ ] whiter
oh my well his dad was the asian one oh
unexpected twist
that's fast that's like boss
tearing up white puss right after world
war
ii had his own pearl harbor real talk
that is [ __ ] fantastic dude the
levels of game that you need
post pearl harbor right to tear up white
puss
as a japanese man i'm waiting for the
day i [ __ ]
get it out get it out of the house
do not
i said i can't wait for the day you guys
big up a black guy for [ __ ] a white
girl the way you just picked up an asian
guy for [ __ ] a white girl now cause
it's easy for y'all actually just
fishing with dynamite
yeah for a for an asian bruh why girls
wanna [ __ ]
yo if if an asian dude [ __ ] a black
girl how would you feel about it
you'd be like oh [ __ ] yeah smack right
he's the underdog he's the under oh
that's a good ass [ __ ] point
wait underdog is a dish
[Applause]